[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and all 12 teams paired up ready to go
[Music]
the reason we teach sales in the MBA
curriculum is because in the real world
of business there are two types of
problems so this is actually the most
critical round you either put yourself
on a trajectory to win or you end up in
the hole but you spend all the rest of
your time trying to dig your way out of
not enough orders and everything else
team 10 has submitted in this sales
class it's about not enough orders so
they probably took my advice to heart I
always tell people to show up with your
first move already planned and we
created the game to teach forecasting so
that we get a bad forecast so we can
show them the problems with getting a
good forecast that was the whole purpose
of doing this thing
levers essentially what they have to do
is they have to make three decisions
first of all have to figure out what
their sales goal is going to be then
they have to set quota across three
different regions then the final
decision is personnel how many sales
managers and how many reps are you going
to deploy to these regions to make your
quota
oh we try to create in a simulation the
environment in the Salesforce is very
interesting we're gonna judge you on how
much you make and how much you booked
and how successful you are and by the
way we want you to forecast and we do
this thing and all of a sudden the class
is on fire by midnight is like a great
decision blood comes up people get
really excited about competing in this
thing we didn't know we're gonna get
that effect and when we got it it was
just gravy for us it was really good I
have a maximum of 10 minutes to read the
results do additional analysis modify
their budgets and then submit a feasible
plan now they've only got about six
minutes left students get to decide what
roles they play yeah are they done send
them off for coffee and tell them we're
leaving back in the classroom
[Music]
what we're going to do is we're gonna go
on from here to have a discussion with
these teams we're gonna find out what
strategies the winners and losers deploy
how did you decide what decisions you
would make who you would hire where you
would deploy your resources what number
you would shoot for and how you would
make that public we started an set an
initial quote of 85 million one hundred
and twelve in the first quarter so what
we were doing was trying to spend less
upfront make sure that our reps hit
quota and didn't quit Wow
yes team three that said almost
identical to our strategy our target has
like 86 million and we tried to not over
allocate the central and we just missed
badly so I think this is actually good
to talk about once we get into some of
the consequences I think it's important
to understand where these kind of
strategies where they don't pan out as
you expect in addition to solving the
forecasting problem which we did we
created an environment where pretty big
differences in the NBA's here have an
opportunity to feel what it's like to be
in a group of people where you get
judged by your numbers as you perform so
so what we're going to pretend Rio will
go at Carnival
[Applause]
game over
I don't know why what happened when a
game is over we can talk about
experience what it felt like of being a
Salesman and that is something they get
I think the system is faulty
I love worry our planning was impeccable
we crushed them with three